we're ready for you mr. crystal on my
way hi hello there mr. host the most
about we make this dressing room and
undressing room it was why you in a row
why aren't you in a robe I have to
introduce Ben still and emma stone right
now so I really have to go and you do
shoe - a friend of mine oh I think
you're gonna like her oh she's a lot of
fun
Wow limber
I still have to introduce bed stolen
Emma Stone yeah I really have to
introduce you to her sister a hit
present the Award for Best Visual
Effects though it's kinda hard to top
this one Ben Stiller and Emma Stone how
did you do this
we are here tonight to present the award
for achievement in Visual Effects and
the nominees are this is my first time
for sending an award yeah I know yeah
isn't it exciting hmm I remember when I
was first here it was very much still
exciting and the nominees are
really let's tell Russian we should have
some banter where you at cocky and then
I shut you down who say I look pretty
and I say no chance funny boy and
everybody laughing you be seem okay with
it
yeah you know I've done this a few times
before and I think it's just best we you
know get to the nominee or we could say
we could say that we had a big song
planned about all the nominees but I
lost my voice and then I didn't lose my
voice and then I come out and I sing
this big song about Real Steel and a
Hugo they're the real deal and you know
oh my god that's good let's do that come
on no no no no listen nobody's know I
know you're excited but really people
just wants to say hi and then read the
winner I could just pull someone up from
the audience and I'm dancing me oh my
god Jonah get up here look let's dance
let's dance
Hey look kid I get it you're new but
perky gets old fast with this crowd you
don't want to be the presenter who tries
too hard what do you mean like a like a
guy who a dress up in full avatar makeup
or something
or a green motion-capture unitard or
Joaquin Phoenix I am surprised you're
not in the Planet of the Apes outfit
wasn't ready in time here are the
nominees for achievement in visual
effects Harry Potter and the Deathly
Hallows Part 2 Tim Burke David Vickery
Gregg Butler and John Richardson hugo
rob legato Joss Williams Ben Grossman
and Alex Henan Real Steel Eric Nash John
rosengrant Dan Taylor and swen Gilbert
Rise of the Planet of the Apes
Joel Atari Dan lemon our Christopher
white and Daniel Barrett Transformers
Dark of the Moon Scott Farrar Scott
Benza Matthew Butler and John Fraser
and the Oscar goes to hugo rava gato
Josh Williams Ben Grossman and Alex
Henning
this is the first Academy Award and
nomination for John Williams Ben
Grossman and Alex Annie and the second
Oscar for Rob legato Alex Henning says
the biggest challenge in creating the
visual effects for Hugo was being the
level of quality established on set by
Martin Scorsese well I didn't expect
this I know it's a huge thrill to be
nominated but it's awesome to win and
it's really underrated I really wouldn't
be here for not the genius of Martin
Scorsese it's a epic thrill to work on a
movie with Marty and especially this
particular movie and the incredible
collaborators all of which are nominated
here tonight and by the grace of
hundreds of artists all over the world
working thousands and thousands of hours
we're here standing up there and we
appreciate that and we want to thank the
Academy for recognizing them and thank
you to our producers for giving us the
go-ahead to do what we did and Graham
and Tim and paramount and everyone